foreign
okay people told me i wasn't going to
have a rowdy crowd this morning so i
didn't bring my gavel
all right
if i need it i know exactly where it is
okay
so
first up is 1624
relative to students with disabilities
participating in co-curricular
activities
and making an appropriation
so it looks like you just want to talk
to him
thank you mr chairman
i'm representative tim lang i represent
belknap for the towns of tilton and
samerton i'm currently the chairman of
the house fish and game committee and i
also serve on ways and means so my
testimonies made really fast because
ways and means is meeting right now
um
so i introduced house bill 1624. this is
a pretty straightforward bill it was
originally introduced by representative
michael moffatt
two terms ago
three terms ago
and what the bill does is it basically
just creates a fifty thousand dollar
grant program under the department of
education
and that 50 000 dollar grant program a
year will be used for
schools
that want to create unified um
co-curricular activities and if you're
not familiar with the unified
co-curricular activities it's
the most common example is in sports
programs where they'll have a a soccer
team or a basketball team that will be a
mixture uh generally a 50 50 or 60 40
type mixture of special needs kids with
neural typical kids
so that they can work together and learn
how that that works
um if you've never attended one of those
programs it's probably the most
uplifting program i've ever attended i
got invited out by special olympics to
one out in convale out in conval
and i could not
i cannot uh say how uplifting it was to
watch
the entire school body watch this
basketball game between the kids
and and what it does
now that being all said i'm also
a little practical about this
i served for six years on my school
board in five years on my school budget
committee and i know that one of the
most
challenging things to do is get a new
program off the ground
especially in our tightening budgets
that we have
and so the goal of this bill is to pay
for that startup cost for lack of a
better phrase right it's about startup
costs it allows this grant program would
be applied for equipment costs so again
i'll stick to things like soccer and
basketball um in the case of us they
need to buy uniforms they need to buy
medical equipment for the tr for to have
that have it on the side of the field
when the team's playing
um there's uniforms as ball you know
soccer balls nets if they need it for
for setting it up so again the idea
behind this program is to offset
just the equipment costs
in the first year of the program the
school is still going to be on the hook
for something so they got to pay the
stipend to the teacher or the or the
administrator i didn't want to do a bait
and switch it's one of the things i
hated most when i was on the school
board was hey we got a federal grant for
that two years later the federal grant
went away
right now all of a sudden you're stuck
paying a full position or a full
something so this is about having
everybody having a little piece of skin
in the game
and that the school board will have to
agree to the stipend and that's going to
be part of their operating cost but the
startup costs that initial 2500 to 5 000
it takes just to get the program off the
ground could be applied for and paid for
by this grant program i will say it's
not limited to just sports so we heard i
last term i chaired a committee
that what discussed the the the
things that are inhibiting
access to these programs in school
districts i currently don't have it
money was the number one thing was we
just on the money to start up programs
but one of the things we heard in that
committee was actually one of the school
districts does a unifor a unified
theater arts program where they
literally put on plays with kids that
are special needs so it's not just
limited to sports it's limited to the
entire range of what goes on in the
school system and where there are limits
um
but again i i i think these programs are
extremely worthwhile if there's anything
that makes a better human being is
watching one of these programs or
participating my daughter participated
in it when she was a senior at
winnisquam
and
again it's the most uplifting and best
thing we can do to create
just good human beings in our school
system that understand
the differences between everybody i'll
be happy to take questions again in the
second year there is a provision in the
bill for the second year money um or the
money that's not spent for the second
year and that is to allow
school systems that have if if there's
money left over after schools apply for
the grant
and we don't spend it all for startup
costs then any leftover money can be
used by schools that have programs that
need to replace equipment because
they've had them for the equip the
programs for so long that you know they
need new soccer balls they need new
uniforms so
again it does never exceeds the 50 000
per year but if there's money left over
it's allowed to be applied for by
schools that have existing programs to
replace existing equipment again i'll
call it the startup cost those
replacement costs to keep that down
in all cases the school's responsible
for the labor side of this whole
conversation
and that's it are there any questions
yes
reps of the heath thank you
representative taking my question so if
i understand this correct correctly
um we would allocate fifty thousand
dollars per year
for first-time expenses for a school
district so they only would be eligible
for one grant
um
so um
i guess that's my primary question
because i do completely support this and
i agree i love these kind of it's just
perfect so to be clear just so i i i'm
not
to be clear would be it'd be one grant
per one program yes so if they wanted to
do a theater arts and a soccer program
they could put two different grants over
those two because they're two different
unified co-curricular programs and they
could have a grant put in for both if
they were trying to ramp it up so man
i'm cheer yes
so that means if um i
am in manchester and we decided we
wanted to do a theater program at
central high school we could apply for
that and we could also do a soccer
program and we could do an act after
school basketball program
um so it would work like that correct
and it'll be up for the department of
education to manage those okay grants
are there any other questions
yes
thank you represent murray sorry
just fine um two questions uh you
addressed the first one kind of i'd like
to just make sure you understand it more
um it sounds uh like there are
logistical issues in terms of a school
not using all the money and it would go
back into the state pot or would there
be an option for the school to simply
keep that money and use it for an
additional
co-curricular program this is i'm sorry
i'm sorry if i was unclear what i meant
was for the department of that that was
regarding the department of education in
the grant so we allot fifty thousand
dollars if we only award grants in in
the amount of ten for startup programs
or we 40 and if for startup programs and
there's ten thousand dollars left in the
grant program at the doe schools would
then be able to apply schools that have
existing programs could apply for
towards that ten thousand dollars to
replace equipment so is that the doe
level not at the school level so if the
school gets a grant of ten thousand
dollars they don't refund the four
dollars and fifty cents so they didn't
spend and i think you just asked or
answered my other question the size of
the grants are 10 000.
no well again i was going to leave that
up for the doe to come and the school
could apply for the grants and then the
deal we can manage you know
so i will tell you that this bill passed
for the last three terms as past
education unanimously out of education
to here um the problem was always i
forgot last term when i put this bill in
and this committee denied it
we uh forgot to put rule making
authority and and and explain it out a
little bit further so this bill is
slightly amended from last term um to
make sure that the division has the
rule-making authority to put into all
the rules and regulations around the
grant program that they could do but i
forgot to do that last year what's the
maximum size the grant that a school
could apply for again i didn't put that
in the bill because i didn't want to
micromanage i wanted to put a the cap
amount and then the
doe i will tell you if i'm serving on
the school board it's anywhere from 20
to re depending on the program you do it
could be anywhere from 2500 to 3500 for
for a sports program
they could also put in for a 500 grand
just for materials for this for the
program so again the amount of the grant
is based on what the school need is and
they can put it in and then do we can
through rules decide whether or not it
sounds like it's a very modest size of a
representative
there we go sorry about that i have
two questions um
so am i understanding correctly that the
um
this
what you're anticipating is that these
would be new programs for a school
district in other words if if a school
district has
for lack of a better term a regular
soccer team for example this would be
what you're envisioning is that there
would be another
uh soccer team that would be composed as
you've described is that am i correct in
it
correct so um i again most schools i
won't say most schools so i'll use
winnisquam as an example because i serve
there
we have a regular jv and high school
soccer team but we also have a unified
sports soccer team which is a third team
that is available
and and one thing you again if if you
think about it this way and i hate to
say it this way because it sounds really
conceited to a certain extent i guess
but
you know the jv and the soccer teams are
the highly competitive students that are
that are into athletics and sports right
they're a whole nother class of students
that enjoy sports but don't get to play
sports right because they can't compete
at the level of jv and and varsity right
so the idea is those students also now
have an outlet and can go play on the
unified team which is they can have fun
they can interact with their students
create bonds all the social bonds that
happen you know there's a when i served
on the school board i read a great study
that talked about kids that participate
in at least two or more athletic
activities have higher grades right and
it allows these students to participate
in those kind of programs
sure okay right you know some may ask
one this is a really sort of different
question i i think i agree with the
other comments this sounds like a great
idea my question though is
um
why and it was as i understand it and
i stand to be corrected but we generally
don't appropriate money in the second
year of the budget and so i'm wondering
you know wouldn't it
assuming as i think we all probably do
that this is a great idea
why do it now as opposed to not next
year in the first year of the next
budget
if you want to change the effective date
and so it's effective next budget cycle
that'd be fine i i just know that we're
delaying the the implementation of the
program um part of this is going to have
to dhe uh i'm sorry i'm so used to
talking to dhhs goe has to um
has to put rules together and things
behind this so again the longer we push
this off and kick this can the later
later it's going to be before schools
can implement i think that a 50 000 ask
is a pretty minimal ask
especially coming from my ways and means
background i just got my report and we
have 173 million dollars in excessive
revenue right now and i know uh the
chairman and i have had this
conversation about how much money it
really is but um but again you know i
think a 50 000 is a minimal ask that
that would make this work and allow
schools to get get going on these kind
of programs great thank you
in the legislation you
say
public school districts so this this
grant would be for our public school
districts
who are normally carry these programs
all schools that carry these programs
that are con considered public schools
are there any other questions yes
represent murray thank you again just to
clarify i'm sorry um
the 50 000 stays at doe and when you
talk about it being distributed in the
next year so and it's we're talking
about fifty thousand dollars so it's not
a lot of money anyway but um so it would
not go back into the general fund or
money so that they would it's a
non-lapsing fund okay thank you
representative
thank you mada chair thank you
representative lang for your testimony a
would you be opposed to having a
a dollar limit per grant added into
this bill
i would not be opposed to it again i'm a
pragmatic guy if you tell me that's the
only way it's going to pass this
committee i'll take that over not
passing the bill at all
however i would also think that
um
some of this may have to do with um
school size right the cost the cost
regionally is differently is a little
bit different so again i i wouldn't be
opposed to it if if you want to add that
but i'd also like think that yeah we can
all we can i serve on jalcar and i can
make sure when doa brings these rules
forward those kind of limits are put in
place as well
go ahead thank you um
and you your response actually brings up
my point my
concern
not fear but my concern might be that
since it is a limited amount of dollars
by allowing bigger grants for
maybe bigger schools would that possibly
knock out the ability for smaller
districts to even have access to any of
the money sure again i would not be
opposed if you wanted to say no grant
shall exceed five thousand dollars and
put that number down give you ten
schools or ten programs that could be
started annually if all five all did and
yet if the grants are less they could do
more
one more matter
one more
all right two one more two three part
question
um
do you have any id how many of these
programs exist right now
so we
we did a survey as part of that
commission if i remember right it was
about 20 percent of the schools have
some sort of form program but a vast
are there any further questions
uh i know that we have this program
unified
sports at kenneth
in
conway
or
in conway and
it's
it's really well attended
the kids are
like it
uh and it's
it's good exercise for everyone so
okay
seeing no further questions thank you
very much thank you i'm running back to
ways and means i got a clerk okay sounds
good
is there anyone else that would like to
yes please
24.
it's very green very briefly i'll uh
share these with you as well
yeah but i think you need to turn your
mic on yes i i i've never been in this
room before i didn't know this room was
here
um
for the record uh i'm uh representing
mike moffat merrimack 9 of uh
representing loudoun canterbury and his
representative lang said i was the
original sponsor of this way back in
2018 representative vladal chair ladle
recall we sent it to interim study
and i was unable to shepherd this
forward last term
due to ill health the voters apparently
get sick of me but uh i'm back in uh in
a big way and and hopefully this is uh
this bill it also is back as rips and
blank said it's been in the mix and
the po and i'll just speak very briefly
the policy aspects as representative
lang said it's passed uh three times in
house education
um and and i'm sure
you already know that this uh
is a way unified sports is a way to
integrate uh players who have
intellectual challenges into the sports
mainstream
and it leads to new friendships improved
self-esteem positive changes and
attitudes and behaviors increased sports
skills a deeper connection to the school
uh
children or youngsters who participate
uh you know in these young athletic
programs improve motor skills at twice
the rate of
youngsters who do not participate and uh
82 percent of the family members of
unified sports participants in the u.s
report that their
their kids their athletes improve as
they said self-esteem confidence and so
these are the policy pieces which which
i'm sure you're all aware of i know the
focus here is on numbers and just a few
more quick comments uh on the
inclusivity which is so important uh
improving student fitness social skills
emotional skills friendships on and off
the field uh which happens in all kinds
of sports i'm a sports guy but
especially
for
youngsters who maybe aren't as
representative language said inherently
competitive athletes this is this whole
program is a is a mechanism a vehicle
to get them to meet people and to
integrate and also to to get
more fit
again a catalyst social inclusion
now students with higher skill levels
might serve as mentors
and this is part of the beauty of the
program is that
the students who don't have the
intellectual challenges so to speak they
get to engage and and
and get
they
profit from this too even the students
who are not intellectually challenged if
i can put it that way you know they
benefit from this by learning about how
to mentor and and to work with and to
have these teammates typically teammates
are
of similar aids there's some questions
about uh you know if there's an age gap
and typically the teams are
of similar age
uh sometimes they're co-ed
oftentimes
uh and there are highly competitive
options as well as non-competitive
cooperative type options and
but they train in the same team
so anyway again this being finance
committee most unified sports teams
options are more affordable and i know
representative lang touched on the
the the fifty thousand dollars and you
know
he just went back to ways and means and
and numbers are his thing as they are
for you
so and again last thing i'll just say is
it is already been touched on
given the
the size of the total budget as you know
much better than me the the 50 000 is is
uh
we think relatively affordable even in
the short term and i know the question
came up you know should we push this
back here and i just would echo
representative lang's comments about
kicking this down the uh again as i said
i brought this up two terms ago and and
it's still uh
not spinning its wheels it's moving
forward here we are but
uh if there's a way to not push this out
of here i hope that you can figure out
how to do that and again it's not that
it's not like football or ice hockey
again you know soccer typically is very
soccer is maybe the most
popular unified sports option um and
that's
probably the least expensive to
implement so anyway
uh thanks for hearing my current
comments i'll email them to you as well
i'm happy to take any questions if there
are any are there any further questions
yes representative
murray thank you again now you've only
referenced sports and in here it says
co-curricular activities and
representative lang mentioned theater is
it your mind that it's only sports or
can you give examples because i i think
i mean this is a fabulous ideas for me
but i would love to see it expanded to
include non-sports i don't and you know
theater is the one that comes to mind
there may be musical groups that you
know could also benefit from this but
you only talked about sports sure great
question and you mentioned co-curricular
activities the original intent
of this was uh tied into special
olympics
which which is athletic but there are
some gray areas where some activities
are dance for example um is
co-curricular and has an athletic
component
some types of dance more than others
so that's a great question and
again depending on what you do with this
when doe finally does the the final
guidelines if they expand this a little
bit to co-curricular activities like you
mentioned that could
include dance or theater
or gymnastics uh that type of thing um
great question and uh
my thought is if if if there's some
motor skills whatever movement uh i
think that
are there any further questions
representative thank you madam chair um
you just mentioned
a
the word uh the words
motor skills involved is that the intent
of the co-curricular out activities
thank you for the question uh i think
the the basic intent again is the prime
sponsor
uh is twofold it's to
integrate
uh there's a social component
integrating
different types of students into the
same mix into the same team
uh so the social component but as i
mentioned earlier there's certainly a
health fitness motor skills uh skill
development um component as well so it's
twofold as i see it social and mo i say
motor or athletic
yes
so would it be fair to say
this wouldn't
it's not your intent that this would
apply to say a math club
or a chess club or
something along that lines sure great
question it kind of goes along with
representative murray's question uh
could it apply to a chess club
i
i think that the the rules that
ultimately are formalized and sent out
to around the state to the districts um
would be somewhat at the discretion of
of d.o.e department of education
and that's a great question because i'm
sure that'll come up
some will say what about my dance club
what about the chess club
is chess
chess is fairly sedentary compared to
most other things but
if if you're able to find the 50 000 i
think that
rules could be
put out there that would i would prefer
to see a bigger tent or umbrella that
would allow
uh you know dance gymnastics even chess
i guess sure
that's in my view you know
you have a follow-up
i do okay
um
i didn't see if you were the prime or
you are on it um
i should ask representative lang the
same question would you be opposed to a
um
a wording in there
something to the effect of a unified
co-curricular
activities with an athletic or some some
uh
physical component to it i'm just
the reason i ask i'm a little hesitant
to just send it off and let
the rules committee uh
the department or whoever make the rules
and then all of a sudden we have
something that maybe wasn't
sure
uh yeah representative lang is the prime
sponsor but have obviously i have a
little ownership because i was the
original prime sponsor so
uh
yes
another good question and uh i
understand what your point is you know
you
are a little concerned about doing it
possibly uh
you know coming up with some guidelines
or some prescriptive wording that might
not be in sync with where you all are at
so my my response would be that uh as
you own the measure now
you could
amend it in terms of the wording to
broaden it or limit it
in such fashion as you think best
that would hopefully move something
forward in the shorter term rather than
okay thank you
good morning everyone good morning uh
for the record my name is sue mullen and
i represent the people of hillsboro 7
the town of bedford
i have provided testimony for the record
that i've just given to representative
murray
which i will briefly touch upon because
the gentleman prior
said a lot of what i had intended to
share with you
probably the thing that i can give you
uh the most this morning
is actual experience in uh being
involved
in
both special olympics and the unified
sports program i was in public education
for 39 years
during that time 10 of those years i was
the co-director of the special olympics
bedford has a community service
component to its high school diploma so
you have to get so many volunteer hours
uh in order to graduate
special olympics and unified sports have
been a huge draw for typical peers
to interface with their disabled excuse
me counterparts
because the message that we're
delivering is that community service
doesn't have to hurt
that you can take something that you
love
like athletics like the theater
and you can contribute to your community
through volunteerism
with your disabled peers who are also
interested in the same topics but may
need support around the activity in
order for them to participate
the startup costs are going to be
relatively small because when you start
a program and again uh as the co-founder
of the special olympics program in
bedford we literally started with a
handful of kids and a few
community based volunteers
and that program in the first year so it
was a question of
equipment uniforms and transportation
for that program because
once you
have a team right you want to go out and
play other people and in order to get
them there we had to rent buses
so that was the kind of cost that we
incurred but the program was small
these uh grants would
are not in perpetuity
as the community becomes invested in the
program
our experience was that we had
businesses that couldn't wait to get in
line to help support our programs and
that they were more than willing to
donate people and
resources so i don't think you're going
to be on the hook for much after
the community realizes
how successful these programs can be
unlike representative moffett i will
tell you i am a co-sponsor on the bill
um
you know playing the game what do tim
lang mike moffatt and sue mullen have in
common
right
this
we have this in common and i do believe
that it should be expanded beyond
athletics because we have disabled kids
who are unable to athletically compete
but may in fact want to sing in the
chorus
we have
kids in the theater program who just
like their typical peers they're just
not interested in athletics they need
the socialization
they need the exposure they need the
sense of belonging in community that
comes with being part of a program or a
team but it may not necessarily be
basketball or soccer that draws them
into
the process and also the volunteers tend
to be different
the kids that are volunteering in a
unified cheerleading program are
probably going to be different than the
kids that are volunteering in a unified
arts program
so
i would be happy i can't tell you i
some of you know i was
here a couple of years ago banging the
drum on this as well with
my friend tim lang and
i i can't tell you how transformative
this is for communities
and the idea that smaller communities
that are struggling financially would be
able to get seed money
to set these things up
i think it is hugely important
being involved in special olympics was
life-altering for me
and i would love to be able to bring
that to
disabled kids as well as their typical
peers and i'm happy to take any
questions that anybody has
thank you
all right let's see oh
i asked a question
and i guess i should i should have i
should have asked this question earlier
and i i just didn't think of it but let
me ask you guys
as i said before this seems to me to be
a great idea
my my only question is
um
as i understand the way the the proposed
bill is drafted it would apply
sort of across the board in other words
the department of education could make
these grants to any school district and
so i'm i guess i'm wondering
should there be some
should we be focusing this more on
school districts that you know face a
monetary challenge in other words it
frank candidly it would seem to me that
you know if we if we had to list school
districts that would
the district that i come from wyndham
and the district that you come from
bedford are probably not going to be
you know are not going to face much of a
challenge to fund this on their own
whereas there may be other school
districts that would face a much greater
challenge so should we limit it in some
way it's a i certainly understand your
question
i will tell you as somebody who was uh
you know at the rotary club with my
handout at the men's club with my hand
out that i had uh
i had a huge challenge in bedford new
hampshire initially coming up with the
funding for the program because this our
school district had nothing to do with
funding us
their in-kind donation was allowing us
to use the facilities
so when we played basketball we had a
dedicated time when the gym belonged to
us
but as far as getting the buses to take
us to keene to play in the tournament in
march
or uh the overnight
expenses to go to the summer games in
durham
all of those things had to be raised by
the local programs and they were not
funded by the school district so
um i i would hate to i would hate to
make for you to make the assumption that
just because the school district is more
flush that they would have greater
access to this
because um
you know i mean the reality is that it
doesn't matter what school district
you're in those kids that are uh
not the squeaky wheels
the ones that are not up for division
one scholarships
are not typically the kids that are at
the top of the list for financing
alternative programs
so
thank you
all right i'd love no because
yeah
we are running um
over time so it's a quick one thank you
madam chair
um
in your testimony a couple seconds ago
you mentioned the word
buses and transportation it's my
understanding that this
bill would not
would assume that it would not but it is
an expense so what i m what i was saying
to you was that
as teams are setting themselves up
even someplace like windham or bedford
is going to have to come up with money
for transportation
even if it wasn't coming out of this
grant
the way the the way the bill is
structured it is limited to
uniforms and equipment and that's why i
asked them yes and that's period end of
sentence
on that yeah my only my only
clarification was that that doesn't mean
that the expense doesn't exist it just
means it's not funded through through
this mechanism
okay thank you very much you're welcome
representative ladd you would like to
quickly i got a book in front of me um i
see for the record my name is rick light
i chair how said i come from haverhill
i'd like to just uh make a point of
clarification here years ago
when i arrived here from
up north
we changed the definition of
extracurricular to co-curricular
and co-curricular has been written into
various aspects of statute here
you can find it in 193e on 193.1
c and also in the compact for
children that are from
military families but i'm going to read
it to you so you really understand that
co-curricular shall include those
activities which are designed to
supplement and enrich regular academic
programs of study
provide opportunities for social
development and encourage participation
in clubs
athletics performing groups and service
to school and community
and that's the design that we have
within our athletic programs
we have feeder programs which are
intramurals and then we get to middle
school where it's intramural slash
athletics and then we get the course the
the the sports programs from freshman to
uh to uh
jv to varsity in in the high school
level but this particular program is a
co-curricular program
and as i see it and as i've always voted
for it it would follow this definition
yes represent murray
it's a quick question but i it becomes
important to me um so when you're
reading this this does not specifically
reference or include students with
disabilities but when i'm reading the
bill i got the impression that it was
for students with special needs or
special disabilities so can i just get
clarified on that
well we had when we talked about unified
sports and we were talking initially
about the special olympics is where this
all jumped off from but then we saw that
there are a lot of students within the
system
that by public education that are not
taking advantage of the co-curricular as
we had it spelt out the athletic
component the the marching bands the
theater all that
and we saw a wonderful opportunity here
to involve students which had special
needs or special
uh areas which
not necessarily all special ed and i
don't see it that way
i see it to any child that needs to have
this venue this opportunity to
participate uh in
co-curricular activities i'd caution too
to relate this thing to just the wealthy
district or the non or and not provide
to the non-wealthy i don't want to slide
down then we've got a judge sitting in
front of us here down the londonderry
area where we're only providing support
and curricular activities or we have to
provide it to all regardless of the
wealth of the community or the poverty
of the community and when we get into
this venue right here we're getting into
co-curricular which deals with areas
that
i believe that we have to have this
opportunity provided to all districts
not just those which have the money to
do it
most of the districts which have the
money do it will do it and they probably
won't come after a grant
but it will be those districts for
example like a manchester which has so
so huge a number of kids that would be
benefiting from this and i i agree with
representative moffitt that we need to
address this program or design this
program to try to
adhere to the definition of
co-curricular and have it available to
all those students and let the local
district decide you know in terms of you
know where are the students going are
they going to go into freshman athletics
freshman sports jv sports
we oftentimes when i was in charge of an
athletic program up in alaska i was very
fortunate my athletic travel budget was
1.5 million dollars
but we also had intramural program which
went on at noon time for kids that was a
co-curricular program it was not a
curricular program so how you design
this is going to be up to the local
are there any questions
yes
the unified portion is the unity between
disabled students and non-disabled
students
so there's no room in this bill
for
okay
good morning good morning for the record
my name is rebecca fernett i'm the state
director of special education
um we did do a fiscal note for this bill
and
did not have any issues with the bill we
can easily put the requirements of
reviewing this into the process we
already have for reviewing grants
it's a very small portion of money that
we are able to handle within what we're
already doing the only
piece of this that i would say might be
a little difficult for us to meet is
that effective date of rule making by
july 1st of 2022
um it just may take us longer to do that
but beyond that we have no issues with
this bill or um
have any we don't have any issues with
so
so what date would you like us to put as
the effective date
i would turn around and ask diana fenton
because she was the one that said
sorry
come up and join my friend becky here um
so for the record
and an attorney for the department of ed
um
we have to just be aware that this
effective date july 1st
2022 for the department to enact our
rules by that date
we would probably be unable to do that
so if you envision that this bill would
be signed into law
april or may maybe even june to put the
department on that schedule would be
difficult so
the department would request
maybe a september date
in division two anything is possible
but i don't know if that would conflict
with
the intent of the grant so we want to be
we want to make sure that all the pieces
come together but certainly the
department can have cannot uh sustain
that burden if we have a july 1st
effective date with recognizing the
passage date that we're going to be
dealing with
so we would just ask that this committee
be cognizant okay question does anyone
have a problem with changing the
effective date
okay
um
and i mean i don't i don't see that as
having any real effect on the program
um
you know whether
whether they uh the schools apply for a
grant in september or they apply for a
grant in january
it's um
the key is
getting the program uh going
okay
if not
thank you and i'll close the hearing on
whatever work session on
sixteen twenty i won't close it i will
recess it
until
after we hear the non-germaine amendment
this afternoon is that enough time
mickey
okay
all right so
we'll recess and if um we run into
problems then we'll
recess again but
that's uh
so just to clarify
when you say enough time you just want
an amendment with the date change
yeah okay i can do that and the only
other thing i would suggest doing is on
line 11 of the bill
it talks about the department shall
include in its biennial budget
sufficient funds i think perhaps i would
recommend changing that to
the department's efficiency expenditure
request its agency budget request versus
a statutory requirement that something
be in its budget i think you would want
to leave that up to the budget process
okay that's a good idea
yes
we're talking
amendments
i i would really like to see a dollar
limitation
um i don't know what that number is but
that way we don't have a single
district getting 25 000 and then
some others
that's a number that can be changed in
the future i don't know what that number
is she left
yeah
my only concern is if we have
10 schools or 20 schools apply or
whatever i don't want to leave that
limitation up to the
room
doe making the rules i would prefer us
to set that initial limit if it doesn't
work out in the future we can always
representative heath
uh madam chair i wouldn't be opposed to
that um
i would think um
based on what i heard each
each district could apply for a new
program
so um i think between five and ten
thousand
oh that's way too high you think way too
high
yeah okay
here we go
i think
i would not be opposed to that
i think some place not more than like 4
000 would cover i was thinking 2500 to 5
somewhere in that range so does 4 000
work that would work for me
okay is that
what
no
no what uh what we're uh we're
discussing is that um
representative turcotte
you don't have to take your code off
we're we'll be okay
yeah
representative uh turcotte has suggested
that we set a
a dollar limit
per grand
and um obviously we know not a lot about
these programs but
we were
thinking
the number that
represent turcotte has said is someplace
between 25
and five
and i said four
so
what the schools might
need
you go ahead i don't care who i don't
what kind of uh
demand do you believe we'll see for this
no idea
i
my only concern when you left the room
was i i don't want some schools being
shut out because others have already
come in and taken up all the money right
so i honestly have no idea what the
demand would be this is not something we
have done through my office um but i
think that we could go into rulemaking
where we say that we would take all of
the applications and then determine how
much each school would get to try to
maximize the amount of schools that get
some money so it may be that they don't
get the 4 000 but maybe they get 2 000
so that more schools can get a little
bit of money we could we could we'll
make that way to say that
um so that we're giving as many schools
as possible the opportunity i think it's
it's also and just for the record diana
fenton uh with the department of ed
i closed this hearing you you you just
that was just a teaser really closely
here okay um it's still open i think
when we when we look at this program and
we've had conversations with the
sponsors about this that uh the
department would
base its rule making structure the rule
making similar to what we did with the
robotics grant back in
a couple years ago years here but 2018
2019 it's before the pandemic so
everything in my life now is before the
pandemic or after the pandemic or during
right so
the robotics rules which is a very
similar program
was before the pandemic and we created
that that rule structure and i think if
we look at the language of that bill and
the subsequent rules it's going to give
us a really nice framework for how the
department will implement this program
and i would suggest the language be
structured as to you know not to exceed
whatever amount this committee decides
no more than correct and then that gives
the department some areas that we can
work on and we can ask in our
application for some more details of
what their program will encompass and so
i think that addresses your concern
that
all districts will have an opportunity
that we're not providing money that
might not be necessary it will be based
on what each individual district
requests so a soccer program
i don't play soccer i don't know that
might be a different cost than a theater
program
right so i think we have to
have it be have the opportunity to
individually tailor it for each district
and what their need is
you're very welcome okay can i recess
the hearing now
may i'm sorry to extend this
[Laughter]
is your intent to limit the up to or no
more than four thousand dollars per
program or per district yeah because you
may have a district to apply for
multiple programs
yeah okay close uh if you're gonna talk
you gotta try i'd say uh per program
okay
would be helpful to the department to
have those pieces in the law which will
then subsequently govern our rulemaking
okay
all right
well i i did not open the other hearing
yeah it's a work session so
okay
uh
so now we've got this for this afternoon
okay
let's see i've got too many pieces of
paper here
this is the work session on
and i
do we have an amendment on this mickey
or
this is a non-germaine amendment you
attached yeah we should have one yeah i
relative to the direct certification
for the medicaid information for free
okay
no that's okay
i know what it says i just need to find
it on my list
zero
eight
seven five okay
thank you
um
are there any questions on the
amendment
i think we're i think we're all in
agreement that um
we want to establish the program
administrator i don't think that was the
question
but are there any questions on zero
eight seven five that i've probably
washed out of my brain but
go ahead um madam chair i think we have
a couple of people in the audience that
would like to talk to the amendment
um ladies if you'd be so kind if that's
okay
i didn't i didn't realize there were
people here
members of the committee i'm jessica
goran with new i'm the deputy director
of new hampshire hunger solutions
sure
g-o-r-h-a-n as a nancy
um today
new hampshire hunger solutions is here
to speak on behalf of medicaid direct
certification it is good for new
hampshire children and schools
medicaid direct certification means that
children already receiving medicaid and
whose family's income is below 130
percent of the federal poverty level
which is equivalent to free meals in
schools and 185 percent
which is reduced meals would be directly
certified through electronic data
matching for free and reduced meals at
school without their families needing to
submit an application
medicaid direct certification has
numerous benefits for children and for
schools
and the benefits to children are
children who eat breakfast and lunch at
school
have improved academic performance have
reduced behavioral problems make fewer
trips to the school nurse with stomach
and headaches that are related to hunger
have stronger attendance and stronger
graduation rates
more children in the state would be
eligible to eat free meals at school
school
through the usda community eligibility
provision
more directly certified children means
more
schools would be eligible to implement
the community eligibility program which
allows high poverty schools to offer
school meals at no charge to all
students without an application this
will further reduce errors in paperwork
and eliminate barriers to healthy school
meals
the benefits to school it increases
there's an increase in free and reduced
meal counts and resulting in an increase
in state adequacy grants
reduced administrative costs related to
processing free and reduced meal forms
reduction of school meal certification
errors
reduction of unbe unpaid school meal
debt
and there's evidence from other states
that have participated in this pilot
program
27 states are now participating in the
demonstration project in florida
illinois kentucky massachusetts new york
pennsylvania and in certain school
districts in california in the first
year of the medicaid direct
certification pilots direct
certification increased by 11.6
and in texas from 2017 to 2020 the
number of students directly certified
okay are there any questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you was there someone else that wanted
to speak
oh okay
uh
[Music]
yeah
yes
this is d.o.e
folks
mark
migliano manganello mark manganiello
megan nelson of school finance mark is
the right answer okay
so
we talked a little bit about
at the committee at the hearing
how this will impact adequacy
and
the timing of this is
if we are successful at entering this
program meaning usda approves it cms
approves the sharing of medicaid data
etc then it would impact the 23-24
school year which would impact the
fiscal year 25 adequacy and in talking
with mickey
fiscal year 25 is a kind of a far far
away
kind of far in the future and it's hard
to really predict what the impact could
be on adequacy
so it's really an indeterminable and
it's really difficult to predict what
this could do to adequacy it would be an
indeterminable increase
because we will have instead of using
our current fnr data we would have
better fnr data that better certifies
using medicaid so there would be an
increase
in our fnr numbers um so just i handed a
there's a
memo excuse me are you suggesting that
our f and r numbers right now are not
good
they are not uh ideal
so yeah if and i i have a memo there
sorry representative
turn your microphone on
please
and talk into it
remember this is being broadcast and i'm
sure there are
thousands of people out there just
waiting to hear our every word
thank you madam chair
uh
my question was that um
using this certified through electronic
data data matching is more would be more
accurate
than what we're using now
correct it would help us identify
students experiencing poverty better
than our current methods
so
the
if this i did a town by town handout
and uh if you look at the first column
it shows 167 000 students 159 000
students that's our base adm that's how
many students we have in
school year 2020 and then school year uh
22. so we have declining enrollment that
just shows you that but if you look at
the next middle column there that shows
the decline in fnr data and some of you
saw this back when we were doing the
2223 budget
we went from having forty five thousand
f r students pre pandemic and then if
you skip over two columns
we had about thirty eight thousand so
about a fourteen percent drop
so our fnr numbers are impacted as we
talked about by the universal waiver by
usda
said that no one needs to fill out the
application to get
free and reduced price meal
access so there's not an incentive to
develop the application therefore we
have not as quality data
this is also
regardless of the usda waiver districts
are constantly
as representative of berger as talked
about districts are constantly
hounding families to get their
applications in so it's an
administrative burden as well so as the
previous testimony discussed it would be
eliminate some administrative burdens on
schools and families
but the impact on adequacy would be to
better bring our adequacy numbers up our
fnr numbers that we use inadequacy to
something that matches closer to reality
but what those numbers will end up will
be well i've i have no clue but just
looking at the medicaid numbers we have
70 000 medicaid students
sorry not medicaid students we have
70 000 medicaid
chil eligible children
but that number is also inflated because
director lipman i believe he testified
to one of the work sessions or maybe in
the last week
right now no one is dropping off the
medicaid rolls currently because of the
pandemic so that 70 000 numbers probably
inflated because eventually that uh
pandemic enrollment um
kind of hold harmless that the medicaid
program has that's going to go away so
predicting how many medicaid eligible
students we have in our school is very
difficult without having the actual
student data
but if if we're just throwing out kind
of
guesses which is that's what this is
it could potentially increase funding
in the cost of an adequate education
formula by 60 million
so
i think that's a high estimate i think
but that's that's kind of the best guess
we can have really it's an
indeterminable increase to adequacy in
fiscal year 25 and uh we'll know more as
as time progresses and we get better
data
but just letting you know that this this
will have a cost but we have a really
hard time uh uh determining what that
are there any further questions
i do have one
um
do you have any idea
would
be
national program
so or you know or what information you
would receive locally so dhhs
controls controls and regulates the
medicaid data the way they would trans
transmit that information to doe is
essentially doe provides
i don't know all the data matching but i
believe doe provides dhhs a list of
first name last name and date of birth
and then dhhs will start matching in
their system and sometimes there's going
to be an easy match date of birth first
name last name that's that's automated
the system's going to automate automate
that and match that
then there's some
matching that occurs where
basically hey this looks really close
the first name is maybe spelled with a
as caitlyn uses the example of caitlyn
with a c k instead of a c so they go
okay let's look at this data and see if
it matches but really dhhs has all that
they do them they do the primary uh the
majority of the matching
cms regulates cms would uh authorizes d
program states to do this program so cms
is also looking at the controls okay
okay so all that would come back to you
is not
um
well i guess that's my question what
would what would in fact come back
believe it would come back to us is that
they are
i
uh kelly might be able to answer this
but i believe it would come back that
they are they are just direct certified
okay
the student identifier is not used at
all in this process
uh we have this acid um we have this
acid we know what who the students are
but
uh
hi
let me help you out a little bit
i'm kelly rambo administrator for
nutrition programs and services for the
doe
so mark is absolutely correct the way
that the data is given to us would be
the same way that the snap is collected
so this is a program that is already
currently in place so it would be the
same as that program
the assassin numbers would come and then
it would determine their birthday their
first and last name
and then it would be indicative of are
they part of snap medicaid tanf or any
other programs that we currently already
okay
so
personal data would not go anyplace
that's correct okay
okay
yes so can can i just
make sure that i'm understanding this is
is it the is the process that you're
just that you're both describing
sort of this in other words
let's take it just for a school district
for for
school district x
doe would send to
dhhs
these are the here are all the students
in in school district x
and you would then go through that
and say
okay these
this num these students however many
that is a qualify under one of those
programs medicaid uh whatever the other
ones whatever the other ones are and
would send back
saying
these
these of the students of the names you
sent us these are the students to
qualify is that sort of the way it would
work yes except dhs owns their their
entitlement program data they own that
so they're doing the matching and most
of it's automated
okay but yeah the process you described
and this is the same process we use for
our current program snap tanf
just now medicaid would be part of the
equation okay i'm going to ask you one
question can i just
the one other question and this is
probably you you might be more able to
answer this does
am i understanding from what you're both
saying that medicaid the way medicaid
works
it's
on an individual basis including minors
in other words
in other words the way medicaid works is
not that for example if i applied for
medicaid and i was qualified then
the the
my children who were minors would also
qualify
in other words is it is it done on an
individual basis including minors or
sure
so that would be a a better question for
dhhs since they are the ones that
actually do the determination of it
that's not at a doe level so i don't
want to speak to that
but just so you understand the process
that we're doing here is that we already
have a process in place for this it's
realistically just adding another column
onto our data that we already have
collected
so we already have the processes in
place for it
it's just adding another column onto it
for that
if it gets approved and everything kind
of goes through just so you understand
yes represent murray
thank you
uh i proposed the 60 million i was going
to say 60 000. that would have been nice
i proposed 60 million is it appropriate
to say that
in one sense we actually already owe
this money to the schools but we are not
distributing it to the schools because
we have faulty data around free and
reduced lunch
yeah
if you could you could definitely say
that
i wouldn't say that
i would i would i would i would say
i i would say
you know what i'm saying
i would say
that
parental responsibility
is causing
that to happen
and that that's why
not that we don't think parents are
responsible
but sometimes their children are not
responsible and that's one of the major
reasons that we have this push so that
we can
hopefully
identify
all the children
and it may or may not
result in increases in individual
schools
so
i hear you
but diff looking at it through a
go ahead represent god
thank you
uh the 60 million dollar guesstimate
just so i'm crystal clear here
that's additional money that would be
sent to the school districts not a
redistribution
of the way it's currently funding is
that correct
correct thank you
if you remember this year we had money
that we were able to send to reduce
[Music]
the swept
okay
we may not have that in the future okay
so
okay yes i'll represent heath
now this is a non-germane amendment to
the bill that we're currently looking at
now
do you need a motion
for us to um
approve
could i please make that motion
that we attach this non-germain no you
just you just need a number so um i
would like to amend house bill 1627
with amendment
rep representative i'm sorry to so
that that is that's a correct motion i
will tell you that
there may be an amendment on the
underlying bill
too and i do have
i do have an amendment
already drafted that incorporates this
and potentially something the committee
may want to consider on the other bill
so
rather than adopt multiple at a time or
multiple amendments okay i'll withdraw
okay so we're gonna have to delay this
uh not necessarily i have something
drafted so if you want to pivot to the
discussion of the efa administrator
position and decide what the division
wants to do with that i have something
for that that
as well
you know this
what was the change
this reminds me of uh hb2
discussions
i i know i know i know
uh okay mickey sorry so i do have an
amendment here uh if you recall um
the appropriation in the underlying bill
um funded the position in fiscal 22 and
23 which given the timelines doesn't
make probably a whole lot of sense so i
have an amendment here that would fund
the position beginning one july 2022 as
well as incorporates the amendment we
just discussed oh okay so it's kind of a
two on one so zero eight seven five is
gone
and we have a new amendment
and you can marry you can make that
motion
no
so
okay
yes i just wanted to
bring to light that
before we had brought up that we would
need a administrative fee to complete
the application for that we had brought
that up in the in the other committee so
that's just something to keep in mind
for this amendment as well too back to
i'm sorry to switch back to the medicaid
um
the medicaid bill
and and may i just say something yes
if you can sit here and promise me that
you will have no labs
other than that which was required
then i might think about it but i am
here to tell you
that every agency out there has lots of
money
and i will also tell you you can bring
that to fiscal
that change
and it will be approved so the answer to
your money question is
i'm i'm willing to do that at our april
15th meeting when my taxes are hopefully
done
okay yes representative i had asked if
um
esser funding would be appropriate
because in
essence this is related to um the issues
we had around copied so um
did you oh good looks like you have a
response for me
so we have posed this question and it is
uh unclear as to whether or not it would
be allowable at this point um it is not
uh squarely to prevent prepare for and
respond to the copa 19 pandemic there is
an underlying issue
in our fnr data that has preceded the
pandemic so that
that would be a stretch of an
interpretation is the sense that we are
sure and
just briefly i know
that the answer to the
request for fifty thousand dollars and
class 102 to enter into a contract it is
currently no but just again reframe and
remind the committee that we do believe
that it would take 150 to 200 hours to
just initially
fill out the application and then an
indeterminate number of hours for pass
back with usda and our conversations
with other states we have heard that
this is a significant administrative
burden and we currently have four
members in kelly's office which is
typically staffed at seven and we have
been administering 34 million dollars as
opposed to 14 million dollars
as was under those
uh
previous seven employees so appreciate
your consideration of that context i got
it
but no
just for the record
yes i apologize i'm mckinsey snow
division director of learner support at
the department of education
yeah i saw mark over there trying to
hide his head on the on the money so
okay
all right now
representative heath i will take your
motion
this amendment
would provide the sum of a hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars for fiscal year
ending june 30th
um for uh an education freedom account
administrator and also this um
amendment will allow for the medicaid
direct certification program which i
have to say i am very pleased about
because i think it will help a lot of
children um and i would like to move
that motion please
representative murray seconds
is that
is the clerk ready or is ready i'm just
shuffling
h all right all right um
let's see representative petrie's not
here uh representative lin votes yes
representative turcotte
no
uh representative yes
representative yes
representative murray yes representative
umber yes
one two three four five it's five to one
representative heath could i encourage
blurb
okay i'm sorry
no it doesn't have to be emotion all
right now we need a motion to approve
hb
okay
all right um
uh clerk votes yes uh representative
turca no
uh representative bucco
yes
representative heath yes
representative murray yes representative
yes
vote is five to one
uh in the affirmative okay the vote's
five to one and the affirmative and
so we finished one thing today i am real
proud of us
so
uh
okay thank you
um
okay
11 o'clock
relative to regional
queer and technical education agreements
so
a
representative lad
did you want to come up and say
something
well thank you very much uh madam chair
and members of the
uh finance uh division two uh for the
record it's rick ladd from haverhill uh
chair house education on 1661 which i'd
like to introduce to you
this is a bill that's uh had a lot of
work through subcommittee work through
working with the advisory council for
career technical education
and a lot of thoughts gone into it it's
been amended and it's
forward it came out of committee on the
consent calendar
that's a bill that's uh
as far as education is concerned
probably one of our top three priorities
in education this year
the bill
sets up rcteas those are regionals
career technical education
agreements which are made every four
years between those schools which are
sending to a cte center and the cte
center
the four-year degree our four-year
programs uh rcte agreements i come
are
have to be approved by the commissioner
of education and the purpose of this is
to
try to have all these sending districts
along with the receiving district have a
calendar which is aligned between those
sending those receiving so we don't have
students in one district saying well
we're not at school today it's a
workshop day for our teachers we don't
go to school
or it's a vacation day
and the but the center is not on
vacation day and courses roll on we're
seeing a number of students which are
missing significant amount of time
so what we've done is we've set up a
calendar
which uh we would like to see no more
than 10 non-conforming days between all
the sending districts and the receiving
districts
and we're not including any days prior
to labor day we know that there's a
number of districts like to start prior
to some that like to start afterwards we
went through a task force that the
governor set up years ago dealing with
this issue and came out with no resolve
but the commissioner has the authority
not to approve any agreement that has
more than 10 days that diverge from the
aligned calendar that we're trying to
come up with however the commissioner
and working with the
sending districts and the and the
receiving district have the option
to to
look at exceptions there are exceptions
provided within this bill due to
emergencies or extenuating circumstances
and those extenuating circumstances as
you know some being on school boards
that there's a lot of issues which come
up where you don't have a school day um
snow day um you have different events
which come up which caused the school to
be closed we certainly have gone through
the pandemic and that's definitely been
a a real extenuating circumstance
there is also a request where if a
receiving district and the
the sending districts aren't in a line
but they're working and making
reasonable progress towards trying to
get this calendar which will afford all
students to participate and have those
number of days that they need that can
be approved but it can't be approved
beyond july 1
2026.
so there there's a cap on the amount of
extenuating days due to calendars not
being aligned aligning calendars is
something that state of maine went
through and they have successfully
gotten there so that the students coming
from the sending school to the
receiving school center are receiving
the number hours which they need to get
that skill certificate
one of the issues which we've looked at
in terms of cte though is that there are
some students that are held back in the
schools for
for reasons such as the course that i
need to graduate is being offered
concurrently at the same time that the
course of the programs are being offered
at the receivings and uh receiving a
career center
we're trying to avoid that seeing just
in previous years we've expanded
participation
uh four attendance at ctes down in
manchester right to grades 9 10 11 and
12 and to all other districts in the
state grades 10 11 and 12. we have a
number of freshmen and sophomores that
cannot attend and get involved with a
course or program seeing that the course
they need in the small sending school
is being offered at the same time
and so i can't attend over there and
that's the career pathway i've chosen so
they get out of sync and but we do know
and we've spoken to a number of school
districts
and centers where the competencies that
are awarded for that particular course
the remaining back-home ad to that get
can be received over a period of time
either through the course or the program
of studies that the person's taken be it
working in some kind of a construction
or diesel mechanics what have you at the
cte center and we know that there's been
some schools very very few because most
are starting to work cooperatively with
the receiving center but there are some
saying you will stay back and you will
take this math course with our math
teacher you will take this chemistry
course with our chemistry teacher for
all the reasons that you can come up and
think about they're probably using those
reasons
but we also know the sending the
receiving center offers those
competencies and the student could be
attending so that's the second part of
this amendment or as the bill has
amended the bill as amended by us is the
complete bill
and lastly we've uh changed the
effective date to july 1 2023
there's going to be
time to get this all in place uh in the
districts and working together we looked
at some of these calendars folks are
developing at this point in time we're
moving very closely with that represent
lynn is on that committee represent
umber as well you've seen those we're
getting there but we're not there and
most of the kids participating in queer
tech and ed centers are from the school
in which that center is located i.e
kenneth is one of them concord high is
another one but if you're from a sending
district to a cte center your percentage
of kids participating is much much lower
and we oftentimes mentioned to you we
need to increase number of students
participating in queer tech education
we compared ourselves to delaware the
state of delaware says the same number
of students as we do in high school they
have upwards to 57 percent of their kids
taking from these high schools taking at
least one course in this state it's down
around 14 17
we need to increase numbers going in
this direction and getting this these
skills that are needed today for our
workforce thank you very much
are there any questions uh yes
representative heath
thank you madam chair this has been a
conversation for as many years as i can
remember
what i never ever could understand i
know when i worked at the manchester
school of technology it used to be the
skill center back in those days
i worked with the school board and i
aligned
me like health care
with a science
curriculum so we had courses
that would fulfill
a course requirement for our manchester
city high schools i'm sure it's gone by
the board of after all this time but
that's something that always troubled me
and it sounds like what you're trying to
do in this bill
is to have an alignment with existing
coursework and align those competencies
so that in fact that student would meet
that competency required for high school
graduation that's correct representative
heath and when you were back in the
department i know we had that problem
and we're working towards that however
the the the need for us to push this
thing right now is we're right there at
that point where
we're not providing the number of
students four careers in the state the
way we need to be doing it and holding
back because there's this this issue
we've been talking about the the
competencies is another issue which
we've really discussed and these
competencies have to be written right
into their agreed with the rctea with
that agreement working with the sending
district so the sending district is the
outfit that provides the the graduation
diploma so we work with them so it has
to be approved there through your rctea
that's the agreement so i think we're on
the proper path
we have a lot of excitement in the uh in
the centers we have some people who i
don't know if i can make that but it's
we need to we need to get by this and
and get on with it and this is a bill as
represented heath just it's been in the
works for
years
in terms of
in new hampshire
in new hampshire some
northern school districts have different
vacations
from
the southern schools simply because the
kids they all do up north
so
my
assumption would be then that the
northern cete centers will be
pretty much aligning their calendars
together
that that shouldn't be too much of a
difficulty to match those up or
it doesn't have to be statewide no it's
not a statewide deal this is within each
region and you know we have the 23
within this state and then we have five
ct centers outside all along that
connecticut river
and there's another issue we're trying
to align calendars
are there any other questions
for representative ladd
seeing none thank you very much thank
you vasso did you want to
a brand new director in manchester at
the manchester school of technology okay
okay before you
continue
i know the clerk wants the spelling of
your
first and last name first and last name
um
okay
and my last name is partinudi
t i
n o u
d i
and for those that guessed what you
daniel ud ideas and dog yes d.i thank
you and for those who guessed that it's
greek you should give yourself a pot in
the back
um prior to
uh two weeks ago working in at the
manchester school of technology i was
the director in milford new hampshire
and i worked as a cte teacher for 11
years
in exeter so so far i have experience
with three centers
and
i cannot
agree more about the necessity to do
several of the
important topics that this bill covers a
couple of things every cte center is
different in milford approximately one
less than 10 percent of our students
were from other districts
but now in manchester approximately 40
percent of our students come from other
districts
and when we talk about regions the
regions are different many schools are a
one school region portsmouth north
conway they are one school region so
there's no need
no great need for calendar alignment but
some others are very complicated concord
nine school districts that contain many
school boards
manchester we have
three towns three high schools we work
with but
then a lot more
milford is i think the best example
within the region there are three
centers
so not only do the three centers need to
work together and align their calendar
but every school that's related to that
region it makes it 21 school boards that
have to sign this regional agreement and
milford has been without one for many
years now i would guess at least four
and the reason for that was the previous
request for the 20-year agreement we
literally don't have a clue what
education is going to look like 20 years
from now so for that reason i
uh support
the four-year agreement
with wholeheartedly
we
also
talked about
calendar agreement the directors
collected information and we looked at
how many days does the average student
miss for who is coming from ascending
school to one of our centers
and their numbers vary greatly it's
between 20 and 80.
like there are 80 days when a 108
year
day
school year that a teacher has to
reinvent the wheel because someone's not
there that day
in terms of resources if we had the same
pd days maybe manchester and another
school district could work together that
makes even more sense for the north
country where
it's even more difficult to put these
events together
and then
i really like the idea that there is an
exception uh that can be made uh for the
centers that have not had the chance to
comply
because like i said it's tough to get 21
school boards to agree on one thing and
three
and 21 superintendents to come together
and agree on this
so having the exemption um makes sense
but what makes the most sense even more
is that we are starting in 23 because
literally the schedules the calendars
for 20 to 23 are already set so um i
love the idea of providing more
courses other than cte courses to city
students that are coming you have to
understand that they come to us for an
hour and a half and sometimes they have
to travel for 20 minutes each way in a
bus that means they are missing two days
in their classes for school districts
that are on a four block schedule they
just missed half a day
every single day on a two-year program
for two years i've had students in
exeter taking vlax classes uh 10 years
ago before you know the day vlogs was
created so having this opportunity to
um
allow these students to stay in our
schools and take that math class that
they are missing
would be
very helpful i feel
and then finally
we talked a little bit about
competencies and
obviously
there is a lot of math in a construction
class in a two-year program maybe not as
much as in an algebra one but the world
right now is inventing micro credentials
and i feel that we can do that too and
maybe we don't cover all of algebra in
construction technologies but at least
we cover
several sections of that and then we can
think about how we get the rest of it it
can be done virtually or it can be done
in person and then
we can give the students the opportunity
to take more city class courses or
participate in more programs and also to
stay in our schools longer and become a
part of our culture also and our
community and that's it
thank you thank you versa are there
any questions anyone has
all right thank you i appreciate it so
much
is there anyone else that wants to speak
on
okay
um
we have a uh
non-germane amendment that is going to
be heard today at
two o'clock
and so
i will
recess
anything i'll recess this work session
to start sometime after
2 30.
because we've got another bill that
we're
waiting on an amendment 1624
so that shouldn't that shouldn't take
too long
uh
mickey i have no problem if you want to
hand out
our non-jermaine amendment we're not
going to discuss it now because we
haven't had the hearing but
look at it over lunch this replaces
1-1-1
yes
okay
turning now to uh
it's amendment number 20
and what we are doing here is
yeah no problem
is um amending
the sum
that we are appropriating for the police
standards and training council
from
uh
350 000
to
175 000
and i we had basically all agreed that
no
we did not
i hope not
the effective date of the bill is
already 1 january 2023
and i think the fiscal note had
included some ramp up time for the
position and i think our discussions
last week were to assume that this
wouldn't start at least until one july
yes
surely
the language in the
language in the bill before this
amendment to change the amount
that that's in italics that was still
part of what we discussed the last time
okay
um i would like to move um amendment
number
one zero nine nine h
and what this amendment does is it
changes the appropriation
um from the um i think it was three
hundred thousand three fifty two um
hundred and seventy five thousand for
fiscal year ending june thirtieth twenty
twenty three
um and uh we'll give them time to um
hire a one full-time staff attorney and
two full-time investigators
okay
all right seconded by representative
lynn
there any comments
okay seeing none
yeah uh
uh
clerk folks yes uh representative
turkish all
no we just put the question you you came
in yeah you you came in soon enough we
agreed on that from 350. yes
thank you representative
yes
representative
okay
is there somebody that would like to
oh
i'm sorry
oh gosh i'm running ahead okay
okay represent lynn moves do i have a
yes
representative
yes representative murray yes
yes
so did i hear you say you'd write the
blurb
i
okay
we have two minutes
to stretch
so
okay
we voted on one
two
three
no
how did we vote on three
oh i was thinking
oh we voted on two
today we voted on
and 1682.
yep
we may or may not ever get through all
these bills
have you taken action on the
um
we don't feel sorry for you karen
we had
no
all right um
we'll reopen the work session on
1665.
so
representative aaron did you have any
new information
that you wanted to
present to us
didn't take action but
i'm just looking for anything new that
you'd like to add
thank you madam chair and
i want to thank the committee for the
time
that you're taking to consider this
after the last meeting and that we had
with respect to this bill
i certainly got the sense that it wasn't
going to pass this committee
um
but that being said i i
i'm very disappointed and disheartened
that our state does not have any kind of
statutory mechanism presently
to give immediate assistance
to towns that have been through
a natural disaster that such as what
acworth and langdon and
and in my estimation you know i wish
that
i could bring some sort of amendment to
fix some of the problems that you might
i would love this to be just an out and
out grant to
our municipalities as opposed to it
being some sort of
you know
legislation where
a
municipality would have to pay a fee to
participate in
being able to
get money out of this fund
i only did that because there were some
senators that suggested to me that it
would be
preferable to have a
method by where towns
sort of participated and had skin in the
game
but
from my
observations and my experiences with
what happened in my town in acworth
you know would have really been nice to
have the state come in and say here
here's some money to help you through
the immediate
problems that you're facing
you know a week or two after after this
horrific
i mean with regard to current statute
these towns can barely pay the 25
percent of damage
after
their
putting in their
claim to fema
and having to wait
so they'd struggle to even pay this 25
percent
let alone being able to pay back a loan
as what current statute provides for
so
i mean you know
acworth eventually did go to mascoma
bank and and got a 2.1 million dollar
loan
why didn't they come to the state and to
ask to the state treasury for that money
well you know what in the first couple
of months
they kind of didn't know what they were
really facing and what they needed to do
and quite frankly
the bureaucracy
to apply for some of this
our road agent and his three crew were
too busy fixing roads to sit down and
and talk to whoever they needed to talk
to from the state to get
any kind of
uh assurance that they would get any
kind of loan
you have a time crunch you have to get
roads fixed and passable and safe for
your people as soon as possible
and we had our road agent consistently
i don't have the time i need to get out
there and and fix these roads
and get them passable because i'm
getting i'm the one getting the phone
calls from people that they can't get to
their house or that they can't get to
where they need to go
and um so you know it's a problem
of of time and getting things put
together as soon as possible which is
why i say
it's a shame
and
shame on us that we don't have a
statutory mechanism to give immediate
we have to look at the level of
bureaucracy
it's too much time to spend on paperwork
too much time to wait for reimbursements
and our out our towns don't have the
time
and they don't have the money
we're looking we're we're
you know what i'm dealing with what i've
dealt with is um the reality
of
towns not being able to absorb
the cost of the damage that's done to
them
and
that's pretty much all i really wanted
to add to what i had to say
i realized the bill has imperfections
maybe wasn't thought through 100 percent
i would hope that
if this doesn't get passed in the form
that it is
you know that at some point we can come
back and
and
do something better
because clearly
something needs to be done we have to
have a solution and
what we have now is not a solution
and i agree with represent what
representative heath had said in the
last time we met was that it would be
nice if we had a pot of money
and that when a disaster hits that the
state can lend its hand
to the municipality and say
here's some money to help you through
what you're going through
so that's all i wanted to say thank you
so much thank you
thank you
um
i'm sorry i
were there any questions
yes tom
oh sorry represent buco thank you madam
chair
thank you representative
um
there's the the two senate bills 402 and
409 have have the responses given you
any
idea of
where those stand or how that how
they're going through or sure thank you
representative bucco
for what i understood with uh sb 402
which was the bill that would say that
that proposes instead of a 25 match to
fema funds the municipality pays 12 and
a half and the state picks up the other
12 and a half of that 25 percent and as
i understand that bill's kind of been
stalled because there's no
understanding of what 12 and a half
percent represents to the state as an
appropriation they have no idea what
number to appropriate or to set aside so
they're kind of trying to figure out
what it is they're dealing with when
they're talking about 12 percent so
that's kind of stalled
the other bill
that is
senator apprentice's bill
which
changes current statute to allow for not
only
a declaration of emergency by the
president of the united states but also
declaration of emergency by the governor
so that's sort of like a
maybe an easier threshold to meet
it
would
be
the time that a municipality could ask
the state for a loan from the treasury
i don't know what other provisions were
made or what other amendments have been
made to that bill
and i don't i'm not sure what the status
if it's passed
i may have passed the committee with an
amendment
thank you did they let me follow up
please um
did did any of those other sponsors uh
uh um advise you that maybe
a bill that would just
outright pay for the roads
no
no there's no such bill like that
i mean it would seem like it would seem
like you know they
when you submitted your bill that
maybe that
you know you got kind of the sidetracked
or
to
for what
to the um
the fema all the fema rules
um
instead of just saying you know yeah our
road is our road's gone we have to
replace it you know
the state gonna help the small towns
that can't afford to do it on their own
right no there's no other bill that
would do that so that's what i attempted
to do with this
only i did add the component of a town
having to sort of buy into the fund
in order to be able to get a benefit
from it later and
in retrospect i wish i hadn't put that
in
okay are there any further questions for
uh represent aaron yes um
um
no my question is for us
okay
thank you
can i
ask our folks
from safety to come up and
just
you're welcome judy
i've got a problem here
uh thank you just for the record fallon
reed i'm with homeland security and
emergency management department of
safety
and
you had mentioned last time that there
was there were dollars available
from the state initially
so correct or am i
dreaming no um so what we have is the
exceptional disaster relief loan that um
senator guida had
pushed through back 2017-2018 time frame
so there's the loan available
which currently which is part of the 409
senate bill to adjust this time
which previously required
a presidential disaster declaration and
a
percentage
interest rate that needs to be repaid
you know with negotiations with treasury
as far as money that the state goes
or state has that would be the only way
that we have the ability to give money
to the communities currently we're still
working with fema on the
disasters from this july and august to
assess that but one thing i did want to
make you aware of
past friday we were just made aware that
because the president signed the omninus
omnibus spending bill those two
disasters
will be at a 90 10 cost share so it's
only a 10
cost share
that the
applicants need to pay back not the full
25. so um
i'm going to work with mickey and let
senator um khan know as well because
that may impact the other loan as well
okay oh that's a good thing yes it's
great i mean fema had been doing that
and we weren't sure whether that was
going to uh
continue or not but that's uh that's a
really good thing yeah so that that
passed through um and we got word of
that friday so
we're doing all the appropriate
paperwork on our end but those two
disasters
representative heath
so
if
god forbid
we had a tornado hit the city of
manchester
and it really leveled
the city
um
what would be available in terms of help
so initially kind of in the couple days
after the event the state is able to
help
with you know personnel or equipment
that sort of stuff but financially we
don't have the ability to do that
if 409 goes through with the adjustments
and
if the governor declares a state of
emergency which he has in the past and
is fairly easy to do compared to
a presidential declaration
we can then loan out money to the
community and then when we work with if
fema reimburses
the community then they would pay back
that but as it stands right now we don't
have any
means to
give the community money other than
through this loan process all right
thank you sure
are there any other oh yes you have a
question okay i'm sorry what was in what
was the number 409 is that senate bill
sb4 yep thank you
and then 402 is the one with the 12 and
a half um
and 12 and a half so the state would pay
12 and a half but we'll make sure that
they are aware that it's a 90 10 split
so
hopefully be able to change the language
to just say 50 and that way it would
cover whatever 50 you know split the
share in half
so
and then hopefully be able to give them
a number that they're comfortable with
and that would make sense in the future
if it goes back to 20 or 75 25.
yeah right now um 402 is just for the
disasters from this past year oh okay so
if we wanted to make a broader um
adjustment that i think would be
something different but this this
specific bill just focuses on those two
disasters that were declared this past
july and august
all right thank you very much
uh is there um anyone else that want to
okay seeing none
is there anyone that would like to make
a motion
can i just make a comment oh sure before
i make a motion that you probably fall
out your chair about
um
would it be possible you know i find
this troubling quite frankly that if
something terrible did happen
you know the governor usually shows up
on the scene and and you know people are
paying attention
but the fact that there is no financial
right away until a disaster is declared
is really troubling um
is this something maybe we should study
a little bit more um that we could ask
maybe for some recommendations about
maybe what should look like what are
other states doing
i just feel like we're leaving people
in a real horrible situation
that that
and on that note
sorry about that
if i may so it varies state-by-state but
we could certainly provide some
information moving forward
many states have a rainy day fund
i did research a number of years ago
and i think it's illinois that actually
taxes
fireworks and that pays for the cost
share you know that kind of thing so
there's a bunch of different things out
there but we could do some research
provide some information but really what
it comes down to is kind of rainy day
fun type things
but we could certainly work on that and
so your
your motion is for interim study
okay
i don't
necessarily have a problem with that
thank you madam chair
that makes me feel a lot better
well i certainly want you to feel better
except
well we've actually been pretty
agreeable today so
does it matter that i can't find 1665 on
okay
i was 1682. that's why i can't
represent romberger yes i feel like i
should just at least make the division
aware of an existing statute somewhat
along the lines of what we've been
talking about just so it's not a
surprise later on so rsa 913d is
relative to civil emergencies and i'll
just read
kind of how it reads now so should it be
determined by the governor that a civil
emergency exists the governor may with
the advice and consent of the fiscal
committee authorize such expenditures by
any department or agency as may be
necessary to effectively deal with said
civil emergency and may draw from any
general funds not otherwise appropriated
so there is
not used overly common not not often but
there is something i know it was kind of
discussed that there's nothing that
exists now i just wanted to at least
point that out to the members before
moving forward
but again that doesn't allow a town to
come in to get it
it would be initiated by the governor
correct right
be
initiated some somehow or other
okay
i have a question from
mickey can you repeat them the uh rsa
rsa913d
ok
all right so we're ready for uh
all the roll-ons yep all right so this
is on the 16
hospital 1665
motion for interim study made by
representative heath seconded by
representative turka
all right representative lin votes yes
representative turca
yes
yes representative murray yes
representative
yes
okay
so
um
we're going to recess until after
the
public hearing on the
non-germane amendment that is scheduled
and um
mickey i have a question for you
i've got a bill here called
relative to the source of funds for
anybody
i don't have it
do you have that bill number
so that bill was itled
oh it was yeah on a while ago actually
um on the middle of february so that one
maybe was on our list of ones if it
possibly passed to be referred here but
okay good i was having a heart attack
over here going
what about
uh
i think i gave i think i gave that one
to somebody else
relative to compensation paid to a crime
victim
i think division one maybe was working
on that one i think so too if they're
not there will be
okay
all right i see nothing else so um i do
have um
the amendment for the co-curricular
activity bill 1624. i can hand it off
now we can still vote on it later but at
least you'll have it through lunch to
just
quicker with that
yeah
oh
okay
that's why we love mickey
you know
yep
he's great
no
yep in 201
uh some kind of training going on
in our in finance
um
when they asked if
they could use the room i said fine
because
it was only one in two that were meeting
scheduled to meet on that day and
so we had our own rooms but then three
yep
okay
uh
is
okay
as i listen to
the
testimony and the comments
um
there was basically only one person that
one person that commented about
negatively
is there anyone on the committee that is
so
parking garage totally agreed needs to
be done
my question that's still not answered is
exactly where
is the money coming from is it partially
ppl is it this is it that or do we care
uh it is basically
you know right right now
179 million
in um
above planned revenue for
the reverend the last revenue focus that
came out
a couple of weeks ago was 191 million
yeah it's
but there's there's a few things that
have to be taken out of that
um you know i mean but yeah that's only
good for the day that it came out right
that's that's right
are we going to
discuss the bill at the amendment as a
whole are we going to do it in parts i
just
i just want to talk about
i just want to
kind of let this one
not have to have a lot of discussion if
we're all
basically in agreement with it
the only reason i i kind of want to
bring the other part into it is because
it's interesting that the other part
is
i'm going to be honest to me is
there's a lot of inequity in it this the
semi guy who owns a semi truck is going
to get a 25 rebate he's i mean that's 10
minutes of him driving you know somebody
else is going to get 25 somebody with a
thousand
but what's interesting about the the
total
was 40 million
which is interesting because we're
looking for 35 million for a parking
garage
so i'm not saying there's maybe
that's that's that's 75 million we're
looking at spending
net
maybe there's a way to
take that 40 million instead of having a
gimmicky
scheme and maybe
using it some other way like towards a
okay
i don't consider it a gimmick um but i
uh i do know and i agree with what
steve said
and several other people said that
we may need to
somehow rather adjust that so that it's
not 25 to everybody
like uh
antique cars you know their registration
fee is whatever
motorcycles are 15
so i don't know we were we were trying
to
relatively easy without
incurring a huge
administrative
burden on uh on d.o.t but
which
we'll talk about that yeah which i agree
because that the original
uh
way we were going to do that my first
question was going to be today how many
man hours and somebody said it was we
so on this one
the only reason i call it gimmicky is
again you've got the semi driver who's
going to get a 25
he's probably going to get more ticked
off by seeing that than he is
you know gonna be oh boy i got 25 back
for the average individual 25 or
something uh
i get somebody mentioned i'll go down
and spend it on a dinner i mean
but that creates rooms and meals tax
revenue so there you it's a good thing
well just a minute
represent murray had her hand up first
thank you
um i guess when i'm looking at this in
terms of a cost to benefit i don't see a
huge benefit to an individual and i see
a significant hurt or loss potentially
to the highway fund and to perhaps even
a broader perspective with department of
safety so i'm in the garage i'm totally
fine with that but i just can't balance
the benefit of the 25 to everybody to
the impact that it would have on the
safety and transportation
it will not have any
adverse impact on transportation
because the money will be coming out of
the general fund it sounded though like
there may be an
anticipated expenses or man
hours per person hours that we may not
are aware of
so the intent of this amendment and we
can clarify that was that the
appropriation in section 7
any costs related to the issuance of
these refunds would also be covered by
this general fund warrant so while there
would be the department of safety
perhaps admins administrative services
and treasury having administrative
functions and the cost of issuing these
checks it would all be paid for by this
general fund warrant not the highway
yes i still it does not tip the balance
in terms of a benefit to an individual
as opposed to a burden to the state
okay
so you have another idea
uh my idea would be to remove the part
that wasn't that that wasn't the idea i
but
well that that would be my ideas to
remove those that part of this and stick
with the garage
so you did ask for
i asked for a recommendation to replace
the how we were going to
give back money but anyhow uh
representative heath thank you for
canceling your four o'clock meeting
not a problem it just goes with the day
it seems um
actually my question is
what is really the purpose
of this
amendment
to me it just seems
i don't want to use the word gimmicky it
just seems to me like is this a ploy
though um we're giving people 20 back 25
dollars
during the last session we were looking
for ways to get more revenue
and here we're giving away money
when we assume you know as i said um in
the hearing
we have so many needs i think of the
department of ed there's not one content
person anymore
i think about health and human services
the difference is what you are talking
about are continual costs and that's the
difference
okay
one time
only
and that's and that's why
that's
that's what this is
because the minute that we start talking
about continual costs
that changes the whole
nature
of what's going on
okay and that that's why
um
we are not looking at
areas that are continual costs
you know you might obviously you favor
education you know i favor safety
uh bob favors justice
um
len i don't know what his favorite is
but say uh
somebody you know and kate has something
else and so does tom and so
we are not looking to create a situation
where
it's something that we have to fund now
we did today
pass i think what two hundred thousand
dollars maybe
that were continual
you know and that's
but we need to do that you know that's
that's not like
millions of dollars instead of this then
could we use the
those funds
to move doj or to that's included down
here all right
i'm biting my tongue because i think
it's a
i'm not going to say anything thank you
okay
so
represent lynn did you have anything you
understand i guess um
you know i i
i i guess it it's in some ways to me it
on the on the
rebate for the registrations it sort of
depends on you on how you look at this i
agree with what i think what everybody
has said that you know 25 we're going to
give everybody back 25
i tend to think that representative
turcotte is probably right that it does
seem a little bit gimmicky on the other
hand
if you if you
if you look at it as we're giving back
to the taxpayers 40 million dollars
that is you know that that does sound
like we're giving back something fairly
substantial and
i suppose you know in terms of
you know let's
let's let's take the uh you know
something like suppose we suppose we
were talking about cutting the business
profits tax by some small amount i mean
which we did well right no i understand
but let's let's even say that it was you
know suppose we were going to cut the
business profits tax by like one percent
instead of tenth of one percent
um
on i i would imagine that there are a
whole bunch of
relatively really small businesses that
that would not make
very much difference in fact it might be
25 for some of those for some of those
small businesses or 100 or 200 or
whatever and again if you looked at it
just
on an individual basis you could say
you know okay they gave me 200 bucks big
deal
but if you look at the whole
the whole
you know how much money in total is is
is staying in the in the public domain
as opposed to going to the government
it's probably a pretty good chunk of
money so from that perspective i guess i
can
you know i can i can understand what
we're doing here and it does seem like
it's a relatively simple way to give
money back to the taxpayers and so i'm
i'm
representative murray
thank you apropos your argument um i'd
heard this pertaining to other issues
where there's a small amount that goes
back to an individual and individual
saying why don't you keep it and put it
to some better use that benefits the
entire state for not just one day when
you go out for the hamburger but for the
years and years and years you know like
fix a road repair a bridge do something
that has a benefit to the entire state
that is a lasting benefit and it seems
to me well i have heard people say
they would prefer the money used in that
kind of a situation rather than getting
25 dollars back and going to big geyser
whatever they called
if we did not have
the infrastructure bill
and what is it
how much are we getting out of that
yeah i i don't remember what that number
is
so i mean
i would have jumped on that but
we we already have
a huge amount of money that will be
coming into the state for infrastructure
and so
it it
and if we try to divide up
40 million dollars among
uh the towns and cities it amounts to
about 25 a town
you know i mean that's
maybe it's not that low but it's it's
not a lot of money yeah i hear what
you're saying and i think there's a
difference just basic and philosophy in
terms of it's still a big chunk of money
and fixing one element that benefits
everyone in the state even if it's only
in one location of the state we all
drive back and forth so i think it's
just a difference of philosophy in terms
of working that
as long as the road repair goes to
twin mountain
how's that
you don't care
okay
okay yeah
hang on just a second um
len will you mind taking over for a
second i just need to
go listen to uh
so
can i just add representatives walking
out of the room
why don't we take oh okay the 40 million
dollars why don't we add it to the
governor's 100 million dollars for
housing
and then we'd have 140 million dollars
that we could do some really good things
across the state for a lot of people i
think would be so significant when we
know we have a crisis across our state
right now in housing in my city of
manchester it's horrible finding an
apartment for under fifteen hundred
dollars is virtually impossible
so i think that would be i i would make
me feel like we've done something really
good with that money if we could add it
to what the governor is already doing
and he'd be a hero
representative one go ahead yeah you
know i guess i have to say and i
understand completely where what what
you're saying representative heath i
guess
i think
my disagreement with you is really sort
of a philosophical one and that is you
know if you say
you know are there things that it would
be sort of nice for the government to do
um i in some sense i can agree with that
but where i sort of where i'm coming
from it's you know there's always going
to be something more that the government
can do and so
you know i'm sort of not generally in
favor of growing the size of government
um and
so from that perspective
you know i'm not uh i'm i'm much more
inclined to want to give
money back to the taxpayers and let them
decide even if it is a relatively small
amount of money let them decide what
they want to do with with the money that
that's you know i but i understand where
you're coming from and you know
reasonable people can disagree on these
things i think
representative heath
she sees pessica
i know you meant um
i don't see how this is growing
government and that it is using money to
do what government is already supposed
to be doing and but i do want to say
apropos representative heath
this this is
there's not 40 40 million sitting
somewhere exactly it's 40 that we would
be extracting from somewhere so i don't
have i can't think about what else we
would do with it because to me it's not
there right now anyway
but it's just the sense of
taking money that
is there for some use in whatever way
and putting it back to where it's really
not going to have a significant impact
on any particular individual
um i don't think i'm out of line
thinking that's 25
is a fairly insignificant amount of
money to any family even you know and i
don't want to
misspeak about families that are in
poverty um but even two people going to
mcdonald's pays more than 25 dollars i
think
so
let me make one comment sure and then
and i have to agree i'll go back to
using my word and that is gimmicky
i can actually
see individuals receiving this check and
going
you got to be kidding me 25 what are
they
i mean
i could almost see people get more upset
by receiving a 25 check when the gas
prices are up three dollars a gallon
from where they were um
and again i i still got to bring up the
the the inequity of the the trucker
versus the
the motorcycle owner or whatever i just
i just see this is a not a good idea and
would like to see it out
representative
you know the only other thing i was
going to say and i and and i guess
you know i
one one of the things that would make a
big difference on this is how much of a
how much of a burden or an extra burden
this would put on the people that would
actually have to implement this would
there be some way
of limiting
who gets the
who gets the money back well you know i
guess as i think of i mean for example
could we say that you know
uh only people and just as an example
only people
um who have minor chil we'd take that
same amount of money and say only people
who are who have registered cars but
have minor children would get
would get you know
presumably that would increase the
amount but maybe that's very difficult
to do administratively
that sounds like an administrative
nightmare to myself and i think
mr lavoy agrees
that that would be an administrative
vlog
well that's representative i know we
shouldn't do this with our without a
chair here but i would like to motion
that we
divide the amendment
i kind of like the
[Laughter]
idea have a motion on the table madam
chair
and uh by representative he's second
invite representative murray
what's the motion
and the motion is to divide the
amendment and
eliminate the um
the section above the rebate
and that way we'd be saving the
so your motion is to eliminate six
madam chair i'd like to speak to that
go ahead
thank you mata chair i'm totally uh 100
behind that i think that
would
cl clear out something that's
would be very uh
detrimental to this bill going to the
floor i think with just the garage in it
i don't see any issues and i think
cleaning it up this way would make the
hey may i sure absolutely speak so i uh
before you while you were out of the
room uh representative heath and i were
having a discussion and a respectful
disagreement about about
the issue of like what i think what she
would say is don't
don't
take this take the part about the rebate
out and let's use the money for some
other worthwhile purpose
what i would
and what i disagreed about is i thought
that giving money back to the taxpayers
was important but i think what i could
because i do agree with representative
turcotte and i think with sort of
everybody here
that that there is a certain amount of
gimmickiness to the money the amount of
money that we've been giving back and i
guess i could go along with taking it
with dividing it and not approving the
the rebate
with the understanding that we would we
simply would not be saying we're going
to use the money for anything else we'll
just you know we'll cross that bridge
when we come to it i could i could i
could live with that
so
thank you
i just really want to go on record to
say i totally agree with representative
turcotte in this regard
[Laughter]
oh don't talk about squirrels please we
went we went through the squirrel debate
yeah
yeah okay so the motion is to remove
six and seven
from amendment
is that correct uh oh from amendment i'm
q
[Music]
yes
yes representative yes
yes representative
no
okay
so mickey you'll have to have another
amendment right to do that
uh yes we'll have a new amendment
drafted that would just add section
eight essentially it would renumber it
back up to number six uh you you could
go ahead we've done this many times in
the past take a take an action vote now
on it knowing that i'm going to draft it
and then i'll just email it to everyone
once it's drafted rather than having to
meet again no i don't want to we i don't
want to meet again if we can avoid it so
if you want to make the motion to adopt
section eight
to uh
what about the effect of dates
uh the effective dates we would just uh
match it up so that one is effective uh
uh june 30.
so this that appropriation would affect
or would hit fiscal 2022 and we would
keep that intact
in the amendment to 1661. okay so
the effective dates are fine yeah yeah
yeah i'll make sure that the effective
date and the amendment that goes before
the full committee wednesday will be
accurate
there wasn't any question in my mind
about that come on
okay
so um
we voted on that right and that was um
so that will be the same vote when
mickey fixes it all okay
now we'll vote on the otpa
1661 as amended otpa
representative okay i'm sure all right
yes
you know i don't like things that don't
come out of this committee everyone
agreeing
i know you didn't
okay
so we'll
that one's done
now
um
all right students with disabilities
that's the only one we have left to vote
uh steve don't leave
when you're done i mean if are you on
the phone
okay i want to talk to
all right it's uh 16
okay and this is the one where um
yeah is that
yeah amendment one one six six h yeah
so yes you'll see on line ten the amount
of any grant shall be no more than four
thousand dollars per program
and then the other change was on line
14.
adding the terminology of the efficiency
expenditure request the agency budget
request
and the third change was the effective
date based on the testimony from doe we
kicked it to september 1
2022.
yup i have extra copies if anyone needs
it
so we need to
we need to vote on the amendment right
we need a motion on amendment
2022166h
okay represent moves and uh
all right
yes
that's on
amendment
i'll make a motion to approve hp 1624 as
did we have a second on that okay
murray
all right um
so uh quick folks yes
yes
okay
all right thank you
so i need to know who's going to write
okay
61.
7-0
yeah and i'm basically um
just going to say on that one that there
was
as the bill was amended there was no
physical impact
yeah we were all all in favor of that so
if i have this correctly
uh
1547 represent umberger
representative heath
representative murray
uh
representative lynn
and
1665 representative heath
okay
so tom i want to know how you skated
skillfully
okay
are we finished one question yes when we
had uh the gentleman in on that
motorcycle bill from the department what
uh
i think he's the motorcycle king
he doesn't think it is
[Laughter]
okay
all right so we have nothing then for
tomorrow
no
this committee has nothing tomorrow
and i'll i'll see every everyone
wednesday morning
i can't believe i managed to unhook the
everything
at the in 201
word
you